hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today I'm gonna be
going over game from around four of the
2014 candidates tournament today we're
gonna be watching a match between Levon
Aronian he's gonna be the white pieces
and Peter Svidler
will be the black pieces Levon starts
out with pawn to d4 and then we see
Knight f6 upon c4 pawn to g6 going into
the Grunfeld offense interesting in this
particular game both players actually
played the first 20 moves with almost no
time coming off the clock which means
there was a lot of preparation they
didn't really have to think which is
pretty crazy because we don't see the
Grunfeld super often in this particular
line we don't see all the time so that
was pretty interesting all the
preparation these guys have been doing
to get to this tournaments that they can
go through so many moves so very quickly
so nice of f3 pawn to d5 pushing for
developing pieces we see the exchange
off the board again White's looking to
control the center of the board a black
is looking to develop his minor pieces
and then strike towards the center of
the board later on but again it's kind
of that hyper modern defense where black
doesn't care about the the middle right
now he's gonna try to counter-attack
later on and have this being head of
bishop right here on d7 Castle kingside
and then kind of see what opportunities
white presents itself we now see the
pawn recapture pushing forward with c5
trying to break up the defense it would
be extremely bad for white to take here
because there would be a check losing
the rook why it's obviously not going to
do that the set decides to play the rook
over here to b1 you always want to have
your rooks on open or send me open files
so this is a nice little square it
basically blocks that this bishop from
coming outside and doing much because it
could just come down here and take this
pawn here on b7
so we see castle on the Kings side and
then Bishop here to e2 getting ready to
castle on the King side as well we'll
see the take and then the recapture here
on d4 so if we can't look at the board
right here both sides are somewhat to
even there they're definitely even in
material both sides have Castle door
almost castled why it's getting ready to
castle why it's kind of controlling the
center of the board right here he has
both of his pawns right here he is
pretty active rook here on b1
very different than they rook here on a
ate the other rooks aren't doing too
much but white definitely has a more
aggressive position but it's not clear
that he has a winning position yet what
black is definitely gonna have to start
a counter-attack get his other pieces
developed in the board and then try to
find a kink in White's armor now from
here black decided to play a pretty
interesting move and it's Queen to a5
now this is a variation that you'll see
sometimes where white gives up some
material this pawn here on a Tuesday
fall but then what follows is a lot of
attacking this Queen all over the board
and it's very very difficult for black
to do too much besides move his Queen
around the board and so that's exactly
what white wants to do he wants to give
up that pawn of material so that he can
rearrange his pieces get them very
active he's gonna go ahead and Castle
pretty soon here and blacks forced to
kind of just sit back hold on to that
palm material but not be able to do too
much with the rest of his pieces so we
castle on the King side and then pawn
here to a b6 again definitely wants to
make sure that he can get this light
squared bishop out here but he can't
because this rook here on b1
now the Queen's gonna swing here to a c2
threatening an attack here also still
defending here but it can really get
involved into the actions controlling
this long C file now the bishop is gonna
come to b7 definitely wants to get more
involved into the action now honing down
here on the square on e4 that would see
Bishop here to see to starting the
attack on the Queen the Queen is forced
to move and then continue the attack now
Bishop here to b4 Queen here to a to
rook here to eat one now protecting this
pawn here on e4
now that rooks gonna swing over here to
c8 attacking the Queen the Queen's now
I'm gonna move to a d1 back again just
kind of hanging back here this Queens
kind of under attack so he's gonna have
to do something
decides to go ahead and move here to see
two attacking the Queen the Queen
doesn't want to sacrifice yet so he
moves back here to e - now the Knights
gonna develop again black really needs
to get his pieces developed into the
board especially once get both of his
rooks he has his rook active here on c8
but
here on a 8 is not doing too much at all
it's not really the bishop come back
here to d3 attacking again White's plan
is just to continue to attack this Queen
his King is completely safe over here
he's still controlling the center of the
board so what's doing exactly what he
needs to do then the bishop back here to
a2 and then continuing the attack with
Bishop here to c4 then this material AK
has a few different options that he can
move so we see Queen here to a4 we've
actually seen this position before
Bishop to a b3 and then from here
White is kind of putting black in the
tough spots in this particular move we
see the Queen come back here to a3 we
could actually instead see Queen to a6
instead Peter Svidler says that he feels
like this is losing by force it's tough
to see exactly how he loses this again
it is attacking the Queen right here but
if they exchange offer even if they
don't exchange it's really tough to see
how black would lose by force the
particular game though he decided to
play Queen here to a3 and white has a
few different options one of his options
would be pawn here to a5 trying to kind
of choke down the defense from black the
dark square bishop kind of loses a lot
of its mobility another one would be
Queen - III more centralized defending
this pawn here on a d4 also another
defender on this Bishop on b3 and then
the last move what Levon Aronian
actually played I'm excited he did
because it's probably the most exciting
he could have is Bishop takes here on f7
kind of crazy move if you think about it
but giving up that material sacrifice
for the King to come out and white has a
strong attack so the King's going to
take again white gave up this pawn early
on on a3 on excuse me on a tutu the
Queen now he's giving up a bishop on f7
because again a lot of times it's not
about the material it's about the dogs
you have in the fight and white thinks
he has the pieces on the board to go
ahead and start attacking his opponent
so after King here to f7 we see the
bishop -
for centralizing attacking the king
after the the pond comes to e6 stopping
that now we get the knight involved some
knight here to g5 again the Levon
Aronian starting to really attack after
the king now moves now the Knights gonna
swing in take here on e6 the King here
on e8 is completely exposed yes black is
up in material but he's definitely gonna
have his work cut out for him trying to
stop all the attackers that white has on
board white really needs to get his
rooks involved he is protecting this
pawn on e4 he can start to push forward
he has to pass pawns and the stern of
the boards which are always dangerous he
needs to get his other rook involved
into the game it's dark square bishop
can be a huge benefit to him so that's
kind of what both sides are looking to
do Black's just trying to hold on as
long as he can if he can trade down
pieces that's not gonna be the worst
thing if he can get towards the endgame
he's definitely gonna have a better
in-game because he has more material on
board black wisely brings his queen back
here to e7 again he didn't have any real
defense in front of his Queen so he
decides to bring his most trusted Ally
is queen back here to e7 now in the
particular game as I was watching I
really expected to see pawn to d5 I
thought this was a clear-cut way anytime
you are attacking especially if you have
been giving up some material you don't
want to give up any more material and
pawn to d5 does a lot of things but it
strengthens has a nice little outpost
here on e6 also threatens this night
here on c5 in the particular game though
pretty interesting move I think from
Levon Aronian
and he plays Knight takes here on g7
giving up material here on d7 again he
kind of wants to open up the door for
his pawns here on d4 and e4 he doesn't
want to have anything to get in the way
and I guess he just wanted to go ahead
and and trade that material he didn't
want to have to worry about this dark
squared bishop kind of ruining his fun
for these past pawns here in the center
of the board then we're gonna see a
bishop here to d3 again against needs to
be a little more centralized he also has
the threat of pawn here to d5 attacking
the knight and also he discovered attack
on the Queen here on d7 so black has to
be very very careful about that decides
to play his knight back hat
to d8 now he did have other options he
could have taken with his night here on
d4 this opens up a lot of crazy stuff it
is attacking the Queen right here so
again he can't do anything too crazy if
we do see the take with the Queen here
on d4 then we would just see take and
then take and then Black's gonna be fine
in this position again it's now four
pawns to four pawns they've kind of gone
back to what they were before as far as
equality well this is manageable for
black he at this point would probably be
okay getting a draw but in this
particular case he decided to play for
the win and that is what Knight to d8
kind of implies he doesn't want to go
for the force to line of a draw which is
kind of what we saw previously in Knight
to d8 says okay I'm gonna hold on to my
pieces and I'm gonna try to attack and
play for the win which is always
exciting since last candidates
tournament it was kind of a draw fesh
we're actually now seeing players trying
to go for the win a lot so why it's not
gonna bring this Queen back to b3 it is
being attacked again by the rook here on
c8 so that's to move it now we see the
rook here to c8
definitely has to open up the door for
his other work to get involved into the
game if he can double these up here on
the C file this is definitely gonna be a
strong attack on the Queen side now the
bishop is gonna come back here to a1
doesn't want to have to worry about
these double Brooks here and he still
just wants to control this long diagonal
this is a great square for a bishop if
it can ever get there because it
controls this entire file it can easily
get centralized if it needs to but right
now it has a nice little place on board
Luke over to CAS we talked about always
want to get both your rooks involved
they do well together on the same row or
file and then pawn here to d5 again
White has the center control the board
he wants to kind of cut down on what
black can do this light squared bishop
kind of loses a lot of its mobility it
can't really move too many squares it
can move a eight and it can move to a
six not too many options for him on
board now the Queen's gonna come over
here to d7 and then the Queen's going to
come back here
- Abby - again that Queen was being
attacked by that discovered attack with
pawn here - d5 so it was forced to move
now the Queen's gonna come back here
threatening the Queen over here - a
chase block has to deal with that that's
exactly it does he plays Queen over here
to e7 where it was not too long ago
protecting that Kane the Brooks are
gonna swing over here to d1 and Levon
Aronian is doing exactly what we talked
about he has very active pieces he's
controlling the long diagonals he is
really focused on these push ponds and
the center of the board he has both his
rooks behind him which going in towards
the endgame later mid game it's exactly
what you want your Oaks he's gonna try
to push forward cramp blacks position
and see if he can win this game now
black plays Knight to f7 and then pond
pushing forward to e5 and then rook down
here to c2 attacking the Queen the
Queen's gonna come up here and check on
b5 and the next move didn't get too much
publicity even after the match which I
think's interesting and this particular
case I'm just runnin I'm playing King
here - f8 and then we could see pawn to
e6 attacking the knight swings over here
to d6 it's not really clear what White's
going to do black has kind of blocked
off both of the passed pawns which is
exactly what you want to do if you're
prone has passed pawns you want to block
them off so that any space that they
advance that's gonna be bad for you so
in this particular case I think this is
fine not even too worried about this
long diagonal right here black can
really still threaten at least a draw
potentially if if wipes Witt slips up he
could go for the win in the game though
we see Peters fiddler play Queen here to
d7 white decides to go ahead and take
and now we see pawn here to e6 14 the
knight after the King moves then the
Knights gonna be taken black really
wants to take but he does not want to
allow this pawn to push forward or even
even threatened with a bishop here - a
g7 which would stop the rook coming over
here to f8 so black decides to just go
ahead and right away and play rook to f8
and kind of stop it right away now the
bishop just can't
come here to do seven because then the
rook would just take here on f7 nice
little variation from white he now
brings his rook here to e6 getting it
more involved into the game again this
pawn on d5 right now is kind of chilling
because the rook back here on d1 yes the
bishop is attacking it but why it's
continuing to force the King to move and
the King definitely cannot take it here
on d5 King is forced to move back and
then the rook swings over here to a d6
protecting this pawn here on f7 now the
Brooks gonna swing over here to e2
definitely needs to get involved into
the action palm pushing forward to f2
again trying to put more pieces involved
to attack his opponent rook up here to
e7 putting double pressure on this pawn
on f7 and then we see Bishop here to e5
again what we talked about bishop hangs
out on a1 all of a sudden now that it
has this outpost here from f4 it can
centralize and start to really do a lot
of damage on board some of the rooks
gonna swing over to f7 again white just
kinda has to deal with that he does you
know he's equal in material now which is
fine but you know with those double
druks that's really all he could deal
with now the rooks gonna swing over here
to d6 and Levon Aronian really starts to
just dance this King around the board
the King comes back here to e8 now the
rook over here to e1 we have a
discovered attack if this bishop decides
to move so we see the rook swing over to
e7 blocking that now the rooks gonna
swing over here to c1 getting ready to
come up the board if he needs to and
then we see the rook here to f7 trying
to double up on this seventh ring
anytime you can control the seventh ring
for your opponent if you're white that's
gonna be good so black tries to stop
that we see Bishop here to f6 attacking
the rook here on e7 rooks coming over
here to these seven again black is fine
if white decides to go ahead and
exchange off pieces because if he can
get again get out of here withdrawal
that would be a victory for Peter
Svidler
now that we're just gonna swing over to
e6 a little bit different situation now
that the bishops here on f6 a rookie no
longer come here to e7 then the King's
gonna come to F fates
and then we see the pond push forward no
longer being attacked by the bishop here
on b7 and it's now again protected by
the rook here on e6 then we have King
over here to g8 pushing forward with h4
had a few other options he could have
tried something else but sure h4 is
probably not the the worst move rook to
f8 pushing back bishop here's to g5
protecting both the pawns since the the
rook is attacking it King here to f7
rook here to e1 doubled rooks now he can
play rook here to e7 it's gonna be very
strong bishop here to b6 doesn't add a
lot of value you know he could have
continued with King here to g8 and then
the rook up here we can just continue on
the board again this is gonna be not the
worst thing ever still gonna be very
difficult because there's a passed pawn
here rook here to e8 variation that you
could have seen in particular game again
we see Bishop here to see six and then
pawn pushing forward to h5 pretty
interesting move in the game as well
white could have easily played rook here
to e7 maybe a stronger move decides to
play pawn here to h5 and then black
plays another interesting move again a
lot of interesting moves I don't think
it changed too much in the particular
game but both players again didn't have
tons of time on the clock they were
thinking a lot for these moves so I
think some of them were rushed Levon
Aronian definitely said his h5 move was
rushed in think about as long as he
probably should have I don't know if
blacks really looking to expand on the
Queen side and actually some do
something it seems somewhat illogical to
think that he could push forward to a 1
and actually threaten with everything
that's going on on the King side with
white attacking but again pawn to a5
that's the move on the board and we see
rook here to e7 attacking the key moves
back now we see the pawn take here after
the Pommery captures now the other rook
attacking this pawn it's gonna be very
very difficult we see a check I've put
the King moves check again the King
comes back and then rook here
to e6 there's just too many threats on
board there's no way to really stop all
of the attacks again white also has
these two pass pawns in the center of
the board he has a third pass pawn but
we rule we won't really count that so
again great game by Levon Aronian he
really took his opponents he had
prepared for the Grunfeld opening Peter
Svidler said he had that nice little
deviation playing his Queen down here
instead of Queen to a6 he thought that
game of a fighting chance he later on
said he probably should have just
playing for the draw he did play that
night to d8 which thought would give him
a chance to later on potentially find a
weakness and play for the win
all in all of on Aronian though after
losing that first match to vision on has
come back in 1-2 matches so he's not far
off the lead vision on still leading the
tournament but strong play here by the
number-two ranked player in the world
definitely interested to see how he
finishes this tournament so hopefully
you guys enjoyed the video again if you
haven't already liked the new Facebook
page I'll have a link in the description
and I'll see you on the next video
thanks for watching